Next let's talk about measurement.
Tthis is another corporate of DevOps.
If you want to improve something
you have to be able to measure it.
For instance,
suppose that a new software release is
expected to make the application faster.
How would you know if it
actually does make it faster?
It is not very rational to
say I expect it to be better,
therefore it is going to
necessarily be better.
Sometimes even an expert is wrong.
So when we want to know how
their service is doing or
whether we've improved it, we look to
take measurements of its performance.
Now in traditional IT organizations,
infrastructure monitoring has
been an Ops responsibility.
This includes things like noticing
if a server has crashed or
if an application is unavailable or
if a disk is filling up.
But that's a pretty limited
view on what's worth measuring.
The service is a lot more
than just the servers.
With participation from the development
team, we can get much better monitoring.
Developers can make sure that
applications export useful data,
and they can write services with an eye
to make them integrate with systems for
recording and analyzing that data.
And we could also plug monitoring
into the release process.
For instance, if a new release
causes the software to slow down,
maybe we want to roll it back.
Or even simpler, if we know the traffic
to our service is lowest at a particular
time of day, maybe that's
the best time to do a release.
But measurement actually goes
beyond even dev and ops.
We can use the same measurement
tools to record business metrics,
things like customer activity,
transactions per second,
even measurements of customer happiness.
And we could also measure
the effectiveness of our own tools.
For instance, some dude in a purple
t-shirt might tell you that
using certain deployment tools will
let you do releases a lot faster, but
why should you trust that guy?
You can measure it and
find out for sure.
On the operations side, we can talk
about measuring errors and failures, and
find out whether these new practices we
are adopting are actually reducing them.
Then we'll talk some more about
measurement in lesson three,
where you get some more
in-depth look at monitoring and
some hands-on experience as well.